jeden tag habe ich verhungere ich gucke
so pinguin ihr wollte wissen wie
wissenschaftlich ist eigentlich der hype
um sogenannte ketogene diät auch bekannt
als low carb diät
das problem bei allen nähten ist die
funktionieren es ist unglaublich schwer
an wissenschaftlich korrekte diät tipps
zu kommen und deswegen funktionieren sie
nicht wo hier seid ihr richtig denn ich
bin mal eure chemikerin des vertrauen
seien sie fiel gleich ganz viele
wissenschaftliche infos ob ihr wollt
sicher nicht nur die theorie hören
sondern auch die praxis sehen wie viel
und wie schnell kann man mit low carb
tatsächlich abnehmen deswegen freunde
der sonne habe ich mich für die
wissenschaft geopfert die große
herausforderung auf mich genommen und
sei dann überredet eine woche lang gab
zu machen
[Musik]
low carb bedeutet keine nudeln kein brot
keine kartoffeln kein reis kein zucker
und natürlich auch kein alkohol kein
bisschen angst gemüse und sogar obst
waren erlaubt aber pro tag sollten es
nicht mehr als 75 gramm kohlenhydrate
sein so viel stellt zum beispiel bereits
in drei äpfeln und ich hoffe du hast
wird hinter dir danke dass du es gemacht
hat weil ich hätte es wirklich nicht
hinbekommen
ja ich habe sogar noch drei tage dran
gehabt wie so habe ich das verlange ich
jeden tag die frage wie viel hast du
jetzt in zehn tagen abgenommen
ich glaube ich habe so ungefähr mit mal
ganz kurz warum sollte man dann
überhaupt abnehmen ist abnehmen nicht
einfach kalorienbilanz es heißt wenn ich
mehr verbrennen als ich zu mir nehme
nämlich auch ganz so einfach ist das
leider nicht ob es gar nicht am
menschlichen stoffwechsel einfach
deswegen auch diäten nicht funktionieren
dass mal was sind kohlenhydrate
eigentlich chemisch gesehen
kohlenhydrate sind mehrfachzucker also
molekül die aus mehreren zuckermolekülen
aufgebaut sind es gibt ein
zucker auch genannt monotone sache sind
die grundbausteine von kohlenhydraten
wie fixies beispiel glukose auch
dextrose oder traubenzucker genannt
börse ist der zucker um den sich in
unseren stoffwechsel alles dreht luckow
so kann man sich merken
zwei einfachzucker ergeben gemeinsam ein
zweifach zucker auch die sache ried
genannt beispiele dafür sind saccharose
das ist unser normaler haushaltszucker
oder auf laktose der milchzucker wenn
man jetzt aber längere ketten aus diesen
zucker einheiten baut dann bekommt man
mehrfachzucker auch genannt
polysaccharide diese polysaccharide sind
kohlenhydrate zum beispiel stärker je
länger man jetzt diese kette macht desto
weniger süß schmeckt es einfach zucker
sind zum beispiel süße als zweifach
zugleich erinnert ihr euch noch an unser
video zum x ten extreme das hat eine
mittlere ketten länger und schmeckt
ließen sie das wissen sie wenn man jetzt
die ketten noch länger macht ist man
irgendwann zum beispiel stärke hat dann
schmeckt das gar nicht obwohl
letztendlich alles auf zucker besteht
unterscheiden wie in den nährstoffen
zwischen zuckern und kunst unterzucker
als nährstoff verstehen wir alles was
süß ist also einfach und zweifach zucker
man erkennt sie auch an ihrem chemischen
namen der immer auf böse endet glukose
laktose saccharose hey hey ich heiße mai
und du christian du meinst wohl
christian rose jedenfalls das war zucker
kohlenhydrate das sind wie gesagt die
langen ketten polysaccharide sowas
passiert genau mit den kohlenhydraten
wenn wir sie essen im und werden die
langen ketten erstmal in kleinere stücke
zermalmt deswegen schmeckt brot auch
immer süßer je länger man drauf rum
kauai verdauung und stoffwechsel werden
die ketten jetzt noch weiter zersetzt
den was der körper braucht sind die
einzelnen klose einhalten
klose wird oxidiert strich reagiert mit
sauerstoff und im rahmen eines großen
stoffwechsel zyklus zu co2 wasser und
atp molekülen atp steht für
adenosintriphosphat und ihr könnt euch
diese moleküle als art energieeinheit
unseres körpers vorstellen die bei allen
gebraucht werden was eben energie
verlangt sei es sport oder denken aber
auch so sachen wie atmen oder herzschlag
da unser gehirn läuft praktisch auf
zucker es verbraucht 20 bis zu 25
prozent unseres ganzen energie bitter
der rest unsere garniert mit zucker
beliefert über die blutbahn das türkise
moleküle ist so klein dass es problemlos
durch die food bahn transportiert werden
und genau darüber sprechen wir auch wenn
wir von blutzucker den blutzuckerspiegel
bezieht sich auf den glukose gehalt im
blut genau deswegen unterscheiden wir
auch zwischen zuckern und kohlenhydraten
obwohl die ja alle aus zucker bestehen
aber die zucker können halt sofort ins
blut bzw
die zweifach zucker sind schnell
gespalten die kohlenhydrate müssen erst
mal längere zeit zersetzt werden du mal
denkst du nicht die leute wollen
vielleicht auch wissen wie es bei mir so
war
dazu kommen wir auch noch versprochen
aber wenn ihr ernährung und diäten
besser verstehen wollte müsst ihr ein
paar stoffwechsel basics essener
verstehen und dazu kommen wir jetzt
beide busacca steigt muss der körper
sofort reagieren um ihn wieder zu sehen
wie unser körper mag es einfach nicht
aus dem gleichgewicht zu kommen
zunächst mag es nicht wenn unser gut
zucker zum triers denn unser körper
braucht die kurse und vor allem unser
gehirn fühlt sich sehr schnell lebens
bedroht wenn es kein zucker bekommt die
folge ist die werden henry das habe ich
in diesem video schon erklärt die kurse
geht ja in atp umgewandelt also
vereinfacht gesagt jetzt endlich ihnen
energie dieses atp kann man aber nicht
so gut speichern
das heißt diese umwandlung findet nur
statt wenn wir auch gerade energie
benötigt also mittags schön in der mensa
spitze mit pommes essen dann nehmen wir
mit diesem essen viel mehr kurse zu uns
als in atp umgewandelt
und der rest an glukose ist wenn man so
will zu viel zu viel also ein zu hoher
blutzuckerspiegel schadet langfristig
den blutgefäßen vor allem in ihren und
gliedmaßen
das führt im extremfall dazu dass
diabetiker entweder an die dialyse
müssen wenn die nieren nicht mehr
funktionieren oder zu dem berühmten
diabetischer fuß der dann amputiert
werden muss deswegen zu viel ist nie gut
der körper mag nicht zu viele und auch
nicht zu wenig der körper mag
gleichgewicht so um alles jetzt in guter
balance zu halten scheidet die
bauchspeicheldrüse zwei hormone aus
ersten so die insulin senkt den
blutzuckerspiegel diabetiker können
selbst eben kein insulin produzieren
weswegen sie es sich spritzen müssen
insulin sorgt dafür dass alle sklerose
was zuviel gerade im boot ist aus dem
blut entfernt wird und umgebaut
umgewandelt wird nämlich in zwei
verschiedene stoffe erstens fico gen das
in den muskel und der leber gespeichert
wird und zweitens fed ein fettarmer
ernährung bringt also nicht zu viel wenn
man stattdessen massenweise
kohlenhydrate zu sich nimmt die eben
auch in fett umgewandelt werden sowohl
dass klöco gen in den muskel unter leber
als auch das fett sind wenn man so will
glukose speicher und damit auch
energiespeicher wenn wir also irgendwann
wieder energie brauchen dann wird diese
reaktion wieder umgekehrt und genau
dafür sorgt das zweite hormone aus der
bauchspeicheldrüse nämlich glukagon klug
agonist der gegenspieler zu insulin clou
carbon erhöht nämlich den
blutzuckerspiegel ein wenig länger nicht
zur futter bekommen dann sorgt glukagon
dafür dass das pik rubin aus unseren
muskeln
aber wieder in glukose umgewandelt wird
die da in die blutbahn geschmissen wird
und wieder das hirn und restlichen
organe versorgen kann
die atp um gewalt werden kann damit wir
wieder energie hat es dann hin und
hergerissen war zuckerspiegel steigt
oder körper denkt sich jetzt das ist ein
bisschen so wie sogar blut weg damit in
essen wie eine zeit lang nichts unserer
musiker stücke singt unterkörper denkt
sich jetzt ist wieder zu tief okay das
waren die stoffwechsel basics kommen wir
zur seite du hast in den letzten zehn
tagen verschiedene stoffwechsel stadien
durchgemacht eine sache haben wir ganz
vergessen zu erwähnen saadet ist auch
noch vegetarierin sie konnte also noch
nicht mal fleisch essen und ich nehme an
damit würden sich die meisten menschen
über seine low carb woche retten ich
habe ein kilo gouda gegessen das muss
wieder ag david hat also nicht unbedingt
weniger kalorien zu sich genommen
eventuell sogar mehr habe ihr blutzucker
wald immer tief weil sie fast kein coco
sie hat also ich hatte die ganze zeit
das gefühl essen zum es hat eigentlich
auch quasi durchgehend irgendwie
gegessen ich merke es fehlt etwas wir
haben hunger hunger haben ich war nie so
richtig befriedigt manche werden dann
natürlich auch henry also tendenziell
etwas aggressiv wurde einfach schlecht
drauf abends hatte ich dann noch um hier
und meine freunde auch so sagt irgendwie
was ist denn los bist du so wie mies
drauf ist irgendwas hatte
zwischenzeitlich auch ein bisschen
schlechte laune heute abend was trinken
und haben gerade festgestellt dass ich
den ganzen am mac an wert das stimmt
irgendwann sind dann die
glykogenspeicher auch leer
und dann geht es buchstäblich ran an den
speck der körper geht dann in den
fettverbrennung modus auch klose genannt
mehr dazu auch in unserem video über das
fett weg
die fettsäuren werden in so genannte
kulturen körper umgewandelt und diese
tollen körper ersetzen jetzt glukose als
energielieferant körper läuft jetzt
quasi auf fettsäuren und das
funktioniert prinzipiell auch ganz gut
sport geht
ich mag dass ich tatsächlich genug
inhaltlich habe
ich glaube immer durch soweit und habe
da immer aufgepasst dass ich auch ja auf
den wegen bleiben nicht dass ich mich
irgendwie verlauf und dann auf einer
sagen ja so ein schwächeanfall habe oder
so ansonsten gehe ich im wald verloren
wenn ich mich nicht meldet ist ihr
bescheid aber beim sport ging es
eigentlich voll also da habe ich ganz
normal sport gemacht wie immer und hatte
da irgendwie nicht das gefühl dass ich
jetzt keine energie haben jetzt so weit
so gut aber das gehirn das will glukose
das braucht normalerweise 120 gramm
glukose pro tag weiß ich so dass ich
mich müde oder träge gefühlt habe
sondern dass ich mich dass ich nicht so
da war ich komme ich auf der arbeit
irgendwie überhaupt nicht konzentrieren
also am anfang ging es noch aber so nach
der mittagspause so ab 34
irgendwie hat es da nicht mehr so so gut
geklappt ich glaube mein gehirn verlangt
nach kohlenhydraten und seine kollegen
das bemerkte hier gehört nein das habe
ich natürlich professionell wie ich bin
getan also ich hoffe dass ich nicht
gemerkt
der körper gewöhnt sich jetzt endlich an
alles also nach paar tagen checkt auch
irgendwann das gehirn dass es keine
prognose mehr bekommt und springt mit
auf auf den quito sitzung und ernährt
sich dann auch von den körpern stadt von
glukose hinzu kommt noch ein prozess
heißt glykogen asse wirklich übersetzt
zucker neue erschaffung der körper kann
notfalls sogar selbst kurse herstellen
und zwar aus aminosäuren diese cuneo
genese reicht allerdings nicht aus um
jetzt den ganzen körper energiebedarf zu
decken sondern ist nur ein hilfsmittel
und ein beeindruckendes beispiel dafür
wie gut sich unser körper anpassen kann
alles interessiert alle zuschauer ein
also ich hab insgesamt glaube ich 800
gramm oder so abgenommen
aber ich hätte ehrlich gesagt erwartet
das ist locker zwei kilo sind ich dachte
mir als sie meinte ok sagte du musst das
jetzt machen
da hatte ich mir okay ich mache aber nur
weil jetzt sommer wird dann profitiere
ich da ja auch irgendwie fand in den
ersten zwei tagen saß auch gut aus heute
morgen habe ich mich auf die waage
gestellt und habe mich toll gefühlt
statt über ein halbes kilo abgenommen
aber dann hat es irgendwie aufgehört und
dann ist ja ich noch mal wieder zurück
gependelt oder ein pendelte das da so
jeden tag so zwei gramm unterschied in
den letzten zwei tagen ist es dann
nochmal untergegangen und waren es jetzt
insgesamt 800 gramm ich bin enttäuscht
ich dachte wirklich begeistert uns jetzt
zwei oder drei kilo ab jackpot frühling
800 gramm nicht wieder mühevoll rottet
habe so viel verzicht so ein scheiß
schadet kann es also nicht persönlich
empfehlen für mich wie jetzt auch gar
nichts aber was sagt eigentlich die
forschung bei mäusen hat man gesehen
lokal eng zusammen mit einem längeren
und auch gesünderen leben dasselbe hat
man übrigens auch beobachtet bei einer
generell kalorienärmere ernährung es
geht also nicht nur um die strandfigur
sondern auch um allgemeine gesundheit im
alter ok dazu muss man aber zwei sachen
sagen erstens mäuse können sich deutlich
einseitiger ernähren und trotzdem noch
gesund sein zweitens das was so gesund
ist eine kita gehen diät ist die krise
also der stoffwechsel zustand es geht ja
gar nicht so sehr um die nährstoffe an
sich es geht also gar nicht darum dass
fette allgemeinen gesünder seien als
kohlenhydrate oder das empfehlenswert
wäre auf kohlenhydrate zu verzichten nur
verzicht auf kohlenhydrate oder auf
glukose führt eine nun mal in diesen
stoffwechsel zustand in die kinos und
diese krise scheint gesundheitliche
vorteile zu haben das problem
er fällt keiner durch immer wieder
beobachten wissenschaftler das low carb
nicht nachhaltig ist studienteilnehmer
die sich low carb ernähren nehmen zwar
anfangs schneller ab als andere
teilnehmer schaffen es aber nicht ihr
gewicht langfristig zu halten wenn man
einfach seine ernährung umstellt und
bringt es ja auch was aber wenn man
jetzt so krass auf was verzichtet das
kann man doch gar nicht so ewig
durchhalten also ich zumindest nicht wir
haben ein paar mädels auf instagram
geschrieben die das machen und das voll
cool finden und mit der coole rezepte
geschickt haben aber für mich wäre das
jetzt persönlich nichts man versucht
sogar medikamente zu entwickeln die dem
körper ein kit hose zustand vorgaukeln
obwohl man denen gar nicht durchläuft
dadurch nimmt man zwar nicht ab aber man
erhofft sich dadurch die anderen
gesundheitlichen vorteile die diese
stoffwechsel zustand mit sich bringt
laut einer 2018 der studie von stanford
ist weder low carb noch low fat das
geheimnis einer guten ehe tj wer scheine
so als hinge das mit deinem
individuellen stoffwechsel zusammen in
der studie gab es sowohl in dem lokal
was auch der lowfett gruppe menschen die
mit der methode gut abnehmen konnten und
eben nicht keine der beiden diäten
schien der anderen überlegen immer mehr
experten sehen den eigentlichen
bösewicht nicht in den kohlenhydraten
und auch nicht in den städten sondern
eben verarbeitetem zucker und
verarbeitete getreide wie zum beispiel
weiß besonders wichtig eine schnelle
diät ist nicht vereinbar mit unseren
stoffwechsel der körper ist nun mal ein
meist ein überleben und an meisten
anpassen und ein schneller
gewichtsverlust geht immer einher mit
einer schnellen stoffwechsel veränderung
wenn ihr schnell abnehmen möchte und das
gewicht halten möchte dann müsst ihr
sämtliche lebensfreude wegwerfen und für
den rest eures lebens auf dieser
strengen diät bleiben und deswegen
funktionieren sie nicht wenn ihr
abnehmen wollte oder ihre ernährung
umstellen wollte gold es aber tut euch
selbst eure laune und eurem stoffwechsel
eingefallen und habt ein bisschen geduld
sich ansiedelt hat sowieso keine diät
nötig aber für die wissenschaft hat sie
beste arbeit geleistet also liebe saadet
für deinen fantastischen einsatz für die
wissenschaft und als willkommensgruß
bei meiner klicks natürlich ein keks und
zwar in echten und wenn euch doch
einfällt was wir experimente seite noch
alles machen könnte schreibt es in die
kommentare
ich bin der deb für die wissenschaft
mein name ist und ich bin der deb für
die wissenschaft so lade und wein und
brot und müsli und kartoffeln hre
kartoffeln poltischen gekauft aber ich
bin so gerne essen
aber es ist nicht für mich sind meine
freundin die zu besuch kommen
ich und meine guten klang auch viel spaß